hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're talking about
endospores endo spores are dormant tough
non reproductive parts of a white stage
that some bacteria can enter and you
might say well why is that desirable why
would that be favorable to bacteria to
enter a dormant non reproductive state
well in those spores are produced by
certain bacteria in response to very
harsh conditions in fact these
endospores can be made only by some gram
positive bacteria for example the
bacteria that cause tetanus that cause
anthrax that cause botulism these are
all types of bacteria that can produce
endospore structures when their
environmental conditions aren't very
favorable
now the endospores can protect the
bacteria against a wide variety of harsh
conditions for example they can protect
the bacteria against lack of nutrients
these bacteria may enter an endospore
part of their lifecycle if they are
experiencing starvation of carbon or
nitrogen so if they don't have carbon
and nitrogen that they need in order to
continue their life cycle instead they
may form endospores the endo spores are
also highly resistant to desiccation
this means extreme dryness it's stream'
lack of water the endospores are also
very resistant to extreme temperatures
and this is true for both hot and cold
temperatures also the endospores are
resistant to UV irradiation as well as
many chemicals now it is possible
certainly for the bacteria to leave the
endospore condition and return to what's
called the vegetative state this is
important for human health because for
example the bacteria that cause tetanus
you always hear you get tetanus if you
step on a rusty nail well that's because
the rusty nail may have endospores of
the bacteria that cause tetanus and once
the rusty nail introduces those
endospores deep into your skin tissues
which is a very favorable environment
those bacteria they can then germinate
or return to the vegetative state and
cause disease if you're interested in
learning more about endospores
please see my videos on score ulation
which is the process through which the
bacteria turn into endospores
you can also see my video on how to
stain for endospores so how to see them
under a light microscope and also my
video on bacterial growth and binary
fission to learn just how the bacteria
grow and divide once they have returned
to this vegetative state so that is it
for today and thank you for watching
biology professor